after more than a dozen ballistic
missiles were launched at two military
bases in Iraq where US troops are
stationed President Trump addressed the
nation no Americans were harmed in last
night's attack by the Iranian regime
Iran appears to be standing down while
Iran's leader threatened more attacks he
stopped short of threatening further
direct military action Ron's latest
attack appeared calibrated to avoid
further escalation in the conflict with
the US and for now both sides seem to be
backing away from further military
strikes but in a tit-for-tat conflict
that has been going on for more than 40
years Iran has shown its resilience to
u.s. pressure and on top of a
sophisticated conventional military
capacity Iran can draw upon unique
strengths to inflict geopolitical stress
onto the Western world
so I think what's unique about Iran and
the Middle East is it can draw on three
powerful ideologies first it has Persian
nationalism Iran is one of the oldest
countries in the world and Iran Ian's
are incredibly proud second is Shiite
nationalism the Iranians are unique in
that they're Shiite not Sunni and they
are able to draw on that Shia
nationalism and and make alliances with
their brethren in countries like Iraq
and Lebanon third is the ideology of
anti-imperialism this allows Iran to
build ties with countries like North
Korea Venezuela Cuba punch beyond just
its Middle Eastern allies and and align
itself with countries in anti
imperialist world no country in the
region has these three powerful
ideologies which you can utilize Iran
also has a network of allied militias
and militant groups across the Middle
East that could be enlisted by Tehran if
you look at the entire Shiite world
let's say from India to Lebanon all
Shiite radicals are essentially willing
to go out there and fight and kill and
perhaps even die for the Islamic
Republic of Iran Iran realized that it
could harness its Shia co-religionists
in neighboring countries to almost act
as an arm of the Iranian military and so
they've done what I call the
mcdonaldization of Hezbollah taking that
Hezbollah franchise in Lebanon and
exported it to places like Syria Iraq
and Yemen the Iranian allied Shia
militias have enormous power but not
that much accountability now that
started to change over the course of the
last few months we began to see popular
protests in Lebanon and Iraq which
became increasingly anti-iranian in
nature and I think the assassination of
Bassam Soleimani is really unfortunately
for the United States shifted the
conversation away from Iranian misdeeds
and mismanagement in places like Iraq
and Syria and it shifted the
conversation to the misdeeds of the
United States in a few moments I will
sign a presidential memorandum to begin
reinstating u.s. nuclear sanctions on
the Iranian regime while much of Iran's
crude oil production has been off the
international market since 2018 it's
seen an increase in sales of refined
products like gasoline making up for
some of the losses from sanctions it
hasn't really been able to exploit its
enormous energy wealth because of its
isolation and economic sanctions but
that oil and energy wealth has allowed
Iran to essentially turn its back on
much of the global economy it's not as
reliant as other countries because that
has this free flow of resources coming
through its oil and gas sales another
advantage is the hold it has over the
Strait of Hormuz a vital shipping route
connecting the Persian Gulf to the
Arabian Sea where some 20% of the
world's oil supply passes in July last
year global markets were roiled when
Iranian forces seized the British
flagged oil tanker iran's effective
control over the strait of hormuz has
always offered it a wild card because it
can always threaten to to shut down that
passageway which could really bring the
global economy to a standstill the less
the global economy relies on fossil
fuels oil and
I think the less strategic that card is
for Iran to play following the death of
general Soleimani Iran said it would no
longer comply with limits on uranium
Richmond set under the 2015 nuclear deal
what's key for Iran is to restart their
nuclear program in a way that will
create international divisions rather
than international unity what that means
is they're not going to go from zero to
100 and kick out all of the inspectors
and say they're rushing full-speed ahead
for a bomb because they know that we'll
reunite the Chinese and the Europeans
and the Russians with the United States
they want to move more deliberately go
from zero to 20 which will split the
international community because
countries in Europe Russia China will
point to the United States and say you
were the ones that provoked Iran on the
world stage
Iran largely stands on its own but as
history shows it knows how to frustrate
its enemies without a lot of resources
it's not a country which can hang with
the United States the way that China or
Russia can it's not a global power it's
a regional power but Iran is nonetheless
managed to frustrate enormous ly the
United States going back to the 1979
revolution and since then Iran is
essentially the only country in the
world whose official slogan is death to
America
so whatever the topic is whether its
nuclear cyber Iraq Afghanistan Syria
Iran takes the opposite side of the
United States and so for that reason
it's been a perennial challenge for US
policy makers for the last 40 years